so I'll ease out my line - Gyllenhaal
from Fandango - oh my god because you
know Jake keeps like you I think you're
out as well and you've abducted my heart
and eyes if it was for the gravity in
this room you really sweep me off my
face oh yeah oh yeah
maybe his ego is struggling right now so
just cry for me no it was one bad right
but I was having fun well I want to hear
that one second no no what I meant
totally weirdly comfortable thought can
be my wing mom but I hang out I'm a
occasion chuckle or something he really
is a great wingman actually a good
wingman oh yeah I like he and his wife
yeah my life - the way but I now get a
child that I actually asked about this
movie so I mean the tension in this
movie is astronomical
would you say it's like a horror sci-fi
blend like 77030 this looks good
you can go 8020 and I'm still flying
yeah tennis are you going to Bureau
stolen by one what was the question
something about your eyes and now I've
been about bone structure I'm not sure
what was it again it was like you know
I've got planet Krypton you'll because
of your show oh yeah yeah I've got to
come to that I'm excited that you have a
couple of grizzled zaps
yeah so I can have another four minutes
you have two opportunities - yeah some
very serious time together actually
community over the years I get it out
yeah this is my eighth interview with
you
approximately four minutes each so it's
about 32 minutes for the great
relationship I'm not counting
unfortunately all my time - the other
day
here's which is the walk in the green
one floor yeah I could add but I add
that into the thing they do
yeah they do kids are bastard and I got
added in they already undergrads left
and I haven't even asked a question so
yeah I got a mysterious past experience
a great fear that's 32 minutes of my
uncle
all right yeah third subunit I sometimes
you don't realize that I could hear
Santa marry me later yeah I mean you're
less amazing this one guys are worthy of
sincere musicals well I mean that I mean
what is Hans Zimmer doing all day just
sitting here the violin and their
players work well they're both give me a
rather got certificate may sound bye
okay it's terrifying
it's really it's horrifying when I read
the script I was I mean I got through it
in half the time that I should have and
for a good reason and it's not all about
love and it's not all about inspiration
sometimes it's just about sometimes just
felt like the Internet mm-hmm like hate
and stuff yeah and just hating on people
just generally the judgments the message
that I could only pieces and really
going to pull feeling good in a moment
then afterwards feeling really bad but I
will replay the rest of entities ever
never again think is necessary to know
where is out back 36
[Music]
you
[Music]